okay we'll finish the techniques
around remember throw him past you
so you have this
opening here which is the same one on
YouTube
right there it is
we're just here okay so you don't want
to pin him here in front of you and then
you go you do this kind of thing
a little past you
down
shoulder goes right in place
and uh
are you all right yeah
tight
elbow in front
and stay low and drop his scapula
mechanism into the ground
right to your
knee
boom
what I mean elbow in front is on the
head side of your spine not the foot
side
his foot side of my spine
no elbow on the head side
of my spine
now I'll go slower
and you relax more but what he's feeling
is
that the lock is tightened
um
it's what's freaking about a little
okay
so when you go here
you're going to make a corkscrew shape
relax
on
his shoulder
so this movement
comes around go ahead and go down like I
did it
and
goes right into the lock rewind
it's going to Corkscrew
and go right into the lock
that gives the sensation of tightening
as opposed to
down
then you brought it off and now you're
gonna put it on okay
okay so my recommendation
is
an yogic ritual to release because it is
going to tighten okay
come around you'll see how as I come
around I'm not going to go to the Elbow
it's coming around here
then there's that elbow hand boom
don't undo it
relax
around
boom all right you use it till the elbow
catches up to your other hand
down
and it keeps going around into
the technique
boom
throw the body
use it
until the elbow comes to your other half
down
keep it going around
throw the body use it until the elbow
back into your hands and it keeps going
on
okay
wait
you got old shoulder injuries that
oh my God okay
all right you gotta let him go
okay what what we're doing here
is uh at concentric levels
the very
tactical architecture by which
I be become and remain marshally viable
is also the very tactical architecture
by which I continue to reconcile yin and
yang
by which I have to non-contest
by which I release the ego tripartite
okay so as we as we go along
here we are
you smell the end of the technique the
pin you got it but this elbow is behind
the force output potential of this right
hand you see so for example uh you guys
smell this
smell that you see but is that not bad
hell yeah it is the right hand is
completely outside which means uh this
person here he is stronger than me I'm
not getting him down I couldn't get him
down on the sound he healed up remember
when my elbow control was under my
Center so he's gonna stand up all day
long and I can't do anything go ahead
it's a show I can't do crap about that
okay so
you're gonna move him past you but it's
still outside okay so what you do first
is yield here
do you see and now his elbows come in
more towards my Center Line it's not
that I keep moving him around that's
what you kept doing
so you move in once
then you turn
and now his elbow is where your right
hand is you see that and then down it
goes and I keep the wrist going in the
circle unlock everything
and I drop Coq
okay I'll do that part again boom up
there it is right here move this first
bring the elbow to your right hand down
he goes in around
this whole concentric
matching is what gives Aikido its beauty
you see and it's fluidity
[Music]
but that's also what allows no room for
escape okay
okay so as as you're concentrically
doing all of those things uh and you're
achieving that beauty
um you have to watch your undoing of
things the technique is constantly going
inward on a spiral so you want to watch
your straight lines
and you want to watch your undoing of it
okay so uh what you're doing very common
boom
around
pop
here all good
here see how it's still going that way
okay and then you come down
and then you come back
and he comes off at that point does it
so for example let's unwind the film a
little
and if you're
an opponent
you would always look for the yin
released you see you're doing Jiu Jitsu
so you look for the yin opening and
you'd follow it okay so here I go
there's all yawn going on but when you
feel it going back that's your Yin
opening do you see and you'd be out okay
so uh I don't care
whoa whoa
over here I'll make another note I'm not
going to be in your wrist and feel that
I'm going to be in your Center heal feel
you see
round
okay here we go
I'm going to keep this arm relaxed that
arm that elbow goes down
and then this wrist
is going to go around like that hey do
you see that yes come back
rewind the film all the way
okay
so we're gonna go down
and that shoulder is going to go right
to this knee right you see right to this
knee and feel like your hand does not go
backwards right
see
oh another point I made again in your
body
[Music]
okay
okay so we go slow to demonstrate so you
can see and feel okay
um but the physics changes because the
inertia momentum values are all they're
lowered you see that and then the UK
will milk the out of it and uh and
then you get a uh inaccurate
understanding of what is going on okay
so we go okay
the arm is is more easily extendable as
you keep the energy going
when we go here and all I have is this
tiny lever of push pull you can put your
hand on the mat come on make it go do
you see okay but when you add the energy
not let that arm die that's an example
do you see yes okay now we come around
here
okay
and uh again she's all Slinky do you see
it's all Slinky do you get it go back
but I do the movement oh
the whole body
we get it okay so look at your the
length of your body all right and then
same thing here you were able to put
your knees under and then we get in this
weird position
go back where you were
you're all sprawled out
you get it we just threw her and I'm
gonna actually lengthen her more
do you see she's not on her knees you
get it and so you're in this position
now
do you understand hey do you guys see
that okay so
if I if you're okay and we're going slow
go ahead
you don't want to milk the lower
energetic values you keep the form okay
okay
boom that's it
uh your body will move as a unit
all the way there you go
and then you have a more realistic
understanding of what that final move
does it takes the turtle out of them
okay that arm's not all lowered and
bunched up like that okay
I'd still break that arm though if I had
okay so another common straight line as
you're going around
is this knee is gonna go
I'll just leave your arm there for a
second this knee is going to go this way
that's a straight line see that and it
was cutting across the circle that's
going this way so we rewind the film
okay here uh here
I'm going to make this shoulder stay on
the circle and meet this knee over here
as opposed to put that shoulder down and
my knee goes to you high so it goes in
the circle
that might
make this other knee not touch you all
right that is not important okay the
shoulder pin is this knee stopping you
going forward all right you see hi
stop you going forward that's what adds
to right to the dislocation let's go
right there okay hi
so I would never
if you're down just
sometimes you'll hear
like I'm pinching High I'm pinching you
and I'm holding you and don't know
you're not standing
it's not it okay
so it's
bring his shoulder into this knee in the
arm into the spiral
same thing going back to you lace when
you get here right you were here
let's say you're fine
don't have your hands
undo the spiral
your hands will continue to do the
circle so push down and this hand is
going to come around
this way
not a straight line
so we're here right if this hand is
going to paint the circle this way
you see and this hand is going to paint
that Circle
this way
so my body's going here into
as opposed to here you see the straight
line so
you see they're still in the circles
right locked
my knee happened to match attention's
body but not important to me
I missed it okay
my arms paint the same Circle
okay
try
okay so uh we're going and what I said
was you should feel free
to move your knee
because what this is doing tactically
again you wouldn't necessarily be so
turtle is taking away the turtle
potential okay meaning you want to lay
him out okay so let's let's say he's
he's pretty turnable right now but it
wouldn't be like that at full speed okay
but let's say he is here if I take this
down to where that knee is he won't be
uh spread out so I'm I'm got here
right I'm I'll move that leg again
because the main goal is to get the
Shoulder on the ground and to deturtle
him so I might move it again
excuse me and then there's there's the
circle and I keep it though okay
um as opposed to uh when I saw you doing
coming around and you're deterling
straight
do you see that all right
again that's gonna let him out again the
same thing that adds to the grace and
the beauty and the harmonization of the
yin and yang and the martial viability
and the mechanical advantages right
the opposite of all those things
is going to come from undoing the
pattern so if I try to go straight here
that's where he's going to get out
do you understand get your ass out of
this thing
[Music]
okay but
he tries to go forward now it actually
makes the other technique work better
because his energy is now more energy is
being brought into the
um centripetal energy got it and every
time he touches the ground I have
another Coq point that I can now
internally launch him deeper and deeper
into the inner spiral okay
okay
do you see that hole down you held her
elbow down against her her resistance to
come up okay and then you uh waited the
technique stop it lost his fluidity
you're rushing and you're trying to
muscle this thing down now if you pay
attention
all where you are now
let me let me I'm going to change what
you're doing now so right now your right
hand is in trying to get to Nico
it should be in rokio he'd never passed
through Roku okay and we think if we
hurry to Nico we're gonna get there and
uh
uh try to remember where you are leave
your hands and let go of her
place
and I'm not going to be an ass or
anything
do you think
okay got me
what do you think
because it's in there and I'm just
feeling the in space okay so here we go
foreign
[Music]
I'm all free to move there okay
if we look at what you're doing
you're not doing the tank on in the face
of the resistance
the resistance comes it triggers us and
we want to control it right away but
Aikido is telling you don't seek that
control seek non-contestation so you
have one more ten con to do okay so
we'll go slower boom
here I go
you feel that you see okay instead of
reaching for the technique you're going
to do another 10 con
there's my balance look at my balance
now you see and you're not trying to
stand up no I'm not gonna stand up right
you should pass the rokio
got rokio I'm not gonna come on hold it
I'm not gonna stand up it's gonna knock
me down right so I do the next thing I'm
Gonna Roll my elbow out
and then I put myself into nikkyo do you
see that and so you have Nico and again
I can't stand up and now you use that to
again generate kazushi because I don't
have to stand up I can't continue my
attack this way
so you have to take my balance again
boom there I am now this exposes that
shoulder for you to sweep it down like
you were trying to do in the first
technique okay so don't take your
control off for example go to the elbow
and there's the end space again
keep that turn my elbow down and then
there it is and I'm right there okay
stay there
relax my elbow is on the back side
the foot side of your spine okay so
again usually UK Waits here finish the
technique
when I landed here there's the in space
and again I'm not muscly it's just
Aikido against Aikido or Aikido could
Ikea against Bad Aikido or Aikido
against
bad Jujitsu Okay so
as you come along
boom I feel you that resistance rather
than trying to control it slow it down
and get here here's where you're going
to stand up on me stand up stand up get
out of it go back you're all afraid feel
the hidden energy can you stand up here
no
but as I go to here Santa you see
you could if you can to help you
stand up and punch me in the face
but instead when I feel your resistance
I yield again take violence again move
balance again
okay around there okay that never came
off you see never came off it didn't go
back here
and then I get ready
so I'm gonna put your elbow back here
and you're gonna feel the hints face
towards the rear okay back up
okay I'll come around
and when you feel it going that's it
right there
got it but you're gonna feel that when
done right it just keeps tightening you
see
okay